Guten Morgen lieber. Guten Morgen Tim. Mehr auch nicht.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertzweiundzwanzig.
Schlappsaal, was auch immer das bedeuten mag.
Endlich ist sie zweihundertzweiundzwanzig. Ja, stimmt.
Heute uns ausgerechnet dann,
gibt's einfach nichts. Wow wow mal ein Witz drüber machen kann oder sonst wie wieder nur Terror und Wahnsinn und Überwachung und Pipapo und noch ein Gesetz und hier nochmal hinten eins rein und übrigens
Wir haben mal alle eure Distopien durchgeblättert und fanden die echt geil.
Hält sich raus.
Haben wir die einfach mal alle umgesetzt.
Dankeschön, ja, habe mir nie darüber geredet. Manchmal habe ich auch das Gefühl, wir sind so ein bisschen auch so so mit unserer Paranoia, ne, aber auch äh so die astreinen äh Ideenlieferanten.
Ja, ja, das, ich glaube, dass dass mein, dass wir, wir finden das ja immer, wir empfinden das ja immer als Lob, ähm wenn wir irgendwie von ähm
von, sage ich mal, Entscheidern oder Ministerialmitarbeitern oder Staatssekretären so, ja wir hören eure Sengen, ne? Und dann gewisse, oh hau, krass, ne?
Ja Scheiße, Alter.
Wir haben das jahrelang äh gedacht, ah cool, wir haben Einfluss und können die vielleicht Schlimmerem bewahren, dabei hören die das und denken so, da bin ich auch noch nicht drauf gekommen. Das ist echt hui.
Das ist echt. Echt pfiffige Jungs. Die beiden.
Da haben wir ja noch eine Schutzlücke.
Schutzlücke ist auch so ein Wort, was er lange nicht mehr gehör.
Das stimmt.
Bald wieder. Wobei, bald könnte es, also eigentlich könnten die echt bald weg sein, diese Schutzlücken, ne?
Mut zur Schutzlücke bleibt unser ähm bleibt unser Motto.
Genau.
Ähm.
Ein wenig Feedback anfangen.
Ich glaube ja genau Feedback,
in der letzten Sendung hatte ich mich ja noch ein bisschen gewundert, warum es denn diese hardcordierte Domain in dieser ersten One Acryl Variante gab und was das denn wohl sollte und warum äh wir erinnern uns das Ding fragte nach einer nicht existierenden Domain.
Also, wir reden jetzt von dem.
Hör mal.
War agrided, na ja, Leute, du weißt.
Als die Beatles in unserer Zielgruppe.
Äh werden auch in fünfhundert Jahren noch gehört und äh.
Doch wohl bitte in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Äh ja das kann da so wer weiß, ne? Vielleicht ist das ja die erste Sendung, die in den Archiven nach dem großen Krieg noch äh ausgebuddelt werden konnte.
Vielleicht ist das die letzte Folge, die überlässt.
Also das ist der der Trojaner, der in der letzten Woche Angst und Schrecken verbreitet hat. Ähm und.
Der sich aber ausschalten ließ, indem man eine bestimmte Domain in Existenz brachte, was dann auch jemand tat.
Genau und jetzt war die,
ich wunderte mich, warum das Ding nach dieser Domäne fragt und dann aufhört und ähm die beste Theorie dazu ist, dass es sich dabei um eine missglückte Sandbox-Erkennung handelt. Also ähm,
Eine der ähm klugen,
Oder vielleicht auch nicht ganz so klugen, aber eine der Ideen, äh, die die äh Antivirenindustrie vor vielen Jahren hatte, war, hey.
Wir machen auf unseren E-Mail-Servern quasi so einen Gatefay, was einfach jeder ausführbare Datei öffnet oder jede Datei öffnet und ausführt,
schaut, ob sich irgendetwas in dieser virtuellen Maschine, auf der wir sie ausführen, verändert. Und wenn das Ding irgendwie dieses Betriebssystem dort verändert, dann sagen wir, das ist ein Virus, ja? Also eine.
Von der Idee her sehr schöne äh sehr schöne Gedanke, aber wie das so ist mit den von der Idee her sehr schönen Gedanken. Ähm das verlagert,
den Druck, der auf den Angreifer nur dahin zu erkennen, ob er in einer virtualisierten Umgebung ist. Ja, also man braucht quasi ein.
So wie bei Diesel geht.
Genau, man muss, genau, man man will den Prüfstand erkennen, genau, Diesel-Gate, ja, also und ähm eine diese eine der Sachen, die solche Analyse-Sandboxes und so machen, ist
Ähm alle Domains beantworten in einem Containten Inviroment. Ja, also du sagst quasi du, du führst irgendwie diese Datei wird ausgeführt, ne.
Und dann machst du ein zum Beispiel ein Domänrickfest. Nach einer Domain, die es nicht gibt. Und wenn der beantwortet wird,
sagst du OK ich mach lieber nichts, weil ich werde gerade analysiert, ja? Sei das in ein, in einem in einer forensischen Umgebung, die jemand bereithält
oder sei es eben auf so einem auf so einem äh E-Mail Gateway-Scanner, Pipapo. Also all das, man möchte,
erkennen, ob man in einem in einer kontrollierten Umgebung ist. Und eine der Maßnahmen, die man dafür anwendet, ist einfach nach einem zufälligen Domainnamen fragen
und gucken, ob man eine Antwort bekommt, ja? Und dann weißt du,
diese Domain kann eigentlich nicht existieren, weil es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ich zufällige äh zufällig zweiunddreißig oder so viel Zeilen einander reihe und es diese Domain gibt.
Was passt für eine Dominik? War das eigentlich.
Na ja, jetzt kommt der Punkt. Wenn du das klug machst, wenn du das richtig machst, ne, dann würfelst du dir natürlich jedes Mal eine neue Domain,
damit dir nicht das passiert, was da passiert ist. Die haben aber offenbar, ne? Also XKCD äh zweihunderteinundzwanzig.
Tim muss googeln, weil XKCD zweihundertzweiundzwanzig ist ein äh Codefragment, äh wo eine Zufallszahl.
Ach so.
Hart gecodet wird. Und das ist der Fehler, den dieser gemacht haben. Ne? Also es steht irgendwie Intget Random Number, äh Return vor und in den Kommentaren Chosen bei Fair Dice Roll,
Garantie to be Random. So und das ist das ist genau der, der One-Cry-Fehler, ja? Dass man nämlich die,
statt eine Random-Funktion zu nehmen, die jedes Mal einen neuen äh einen neuen Domainnamen prüft.
Ähm hat hat wurde es hier hart gecodet. Tja,
schwach, aber auch das gibt's in der Welt, das habe ich auch schon öfter gesehen, dass der wie gesagt hier muss eine Zufallszahl hin und dann stand da am nächsten Tag eine Zufallszahl. Ja, ähm außerdem gibt's jetzt erste Studien, die so den.
Die sich anschauen, wie viele, welche Arten von Systemen so betroffen waren und da war, wird ein größerer Teil der Systeme ähm irgendwie als Windows sieben bezeichnet,
was überraschend ist, weil wir ja noch relativ lange darauf rumgewäscht haben, dass er irgendwie Windows XP zum Einsatz kommt und so und das scheint hier gar nicht unbedingt so gewesen zu sein.
Und Microsoft hat ja dann auch noch einen Patch nachgeliefert für äh Windows XP, obwohl sie ja das ja eigentlich nicht mehr tun wollen.
Genau, aber die haben doch ähm wenn ich das jetzt äh richtig erinnere.
Ähm diesen Patch, also Windows, als Windows Expand of Life gegangen. Es hat Microsoft doch für einige, die irgendwie immer noch drauf dependen. Diese äh okay, wir geben euch immer noch Patches für Windows XP,
aber ähm ihr müsst.
Ähm ihr müsst dafür einen Vertrag abschließen, ziemlich teuren Vertrag, dass wir uns bezahlen, damit das uns zwar so teuer bezahlen, dass das äh dass es für euch eigentlich am Ende billiger ist zu updaten, ne? Und.
Ich glaube, unter diesen Bedingungen haben sie ähm wer diesen Vertrag hatte, hat diesen Patch auch vorher bekommen. Was natürlich echt übel wäre. Aber das sind alles noch so Gerüchte, Gerüchte, wo ich.
Verstehe, das heißt sie hätten quasi die Lösung bereit gehabt, aber weil die Leute nicht dafür bezahlt haben, weil ja alles nicht so schön.
Gut, wir haben heute ein äh volles Programm.
Aber was ich gerade gesagt habe, weiß ich nicht genau, ob das äh stimmt, deshalb ich habe das auch nicht mehr so weiter verfolgt, weil wir nämlich heute ein so volles Programm haben mit so vielen Nachrichten, so vielen Schlechten, dass ich noch nicht mal weiß, ob das vielleicht die die inhaltlich schwerste Woche ist, die wir bisher hatten.
Noch ein bisschen Feedback zu unserer Debatte von vor zwei, drei Sendungen über äh,
den Telekom, an die Nutznetzneutralitätsdienst Stream on.
Wir berichteteten und ähm da gab's,
also möchten wir euch auf ein dediziertes Feedback hinweisen, das lief bei Bits und so die Diskussion so aus
Debatte heraus mit was hat dann das sozusagen jetzt für uns als Bits und so, also als als,
Cast, der auch teilweise Videos ins Netz äh streamt oder auch zum Download äh hinstellt, so kleine GmbH. Was hätte denn das jetzt für Konsequenzen
wenn man dieses Abkommen mit der Telekom unterzeichnet und an diesem Stream on teilnehmen zu können. Es war ja auch eine Forderung oder ein Wunsch,
zum Beispiel von Thomas Luninger, der sich da
engagiert, dass er Leute versuchen sollen, sich da sozusagen für zu bewerben in der Hoffnung, dass man dann vielleicht nicht genommen wird, was ja dann quasi schon mal ein Diskriminierungsaspe
wäre nur so etwas zu unterschreiben, heißt halt auch die Konsequenzen äh äh zu tragen, die halt in diesem Vertrag drinstehen und das ist halt äh nicht so schön. Ähm.
Ist euch das mal durch, hört euch das mal an. Timo bringt da ein paar sehr interessante Punkte auf, die wir glaube ich jetzt so im Detail in dem Moment noch nicht diskutiert hatten. Also so Fragestellungen, wie
Was ist denn die konkrete technische Unterscheidung zwischen einem Stream und ein Download, wenn der Download zum Beispiel über das selbe technische Interface geht, dann äh die Frage
Also der ganze Dienst ist ja auch daraufhin ausgelegt auf so Dienste, die quasi so ihre eigenen Apps mitbringen, also wo quasi der Anbieter auch beide Seiten
unter Kontrolle hat, ne? Also wo man,
ja, dann gibt's unter anderem ja auch die Forderung, dass die Telekom Zugriff auf Betterversionen, vier Wochen vorher haben will, ja, von von Software,
Was ist wenn's äh die sozusagen dich gibt beziehungsweise wie das bei Podcast ist, dass ja die Set-Party Infrastruktur überhaupt gar nicht.
In meiner Kontrolle liegt so, ja, also ich kann ja als als Podcast nicht ja keinen Einfluss dadrauf, wie die Podcastlines gemacht werden und was die sozusagen an Qualitäten anfordern oder welches Downloadverhalten die an den Tag legen
Ganz davon abgesehen, dass selbst wenn man äh selber so eine kleine Infrastruktur bereitstellt,
warum sollte man der Telekom irgendwie Zugriff auf auf Betaversionen geben, die man irgendwie äh aus gutem Grund halt auch äh privat äh entwickelt,
Und später eben erst veröffentlichen will, ne? Also im Zeitfall hat man ja da ja auch äh einfach ein konkretes konkreten Business-Konflikt, was ist, wenn ich
Mediendienst mache, der auch mit irgendwelchen anderen Medienangeboten der Telekom konkurriert, ja? Soll ich dann der Telekom nur, um an diesem Tarif teilnehmen zu können? Einblicke in mein internes Geschäftsgebaren äh,
ermöglichen, dass äh geht nun äh gar nicht, ne.
Das aber doch sowieso, dass die, dass die Einblicke in dein Geschäftsgebaren haben wollen ähm.
Ja klar, aber ich meine zunächst einmal versucht ja dieser Dienst diese diese Vereinbarung
vor allem halt so eine so eine so eine so eine technische Rahmenwerk zu legen für wie markierst du deinen Inhalt so, dass er bei uns eben in diese Stream-Ohren, die Fold Kategorie reinfällt,
nur hat es halt eine ganze Menge Implikationen und dann natürlich halt das ganze Haftungsrisiko, was damit zu tun hat, gerade wenn man jetzt wiederum von Zollparty ab,
Das heißt, Dritte können dafür sorgen, dass ich unter Umständen dann in die Haftung reingehe. Was ist bei technischen Ausfällen
technische Umstellung kurzfristig machen muss einfach aus technischen Gründen, weil irgendwelche Rechenzentren ausgefallen sind, weil
ein Dienstleister angekündigt hat, et cetera. Äh ich soll das vier Wochen vorher machen, also ähm,
Soll ich denn vier Wochen auf meinen Dienst verzichten oder soll ich sozusagen sofort alles ändern? Und äh muss dann aber eine Strafzahlung an die Telekom vornehmen, dafür, dass ich äh auf so eine möglicherweise unvorhergesehene
Geschichte reagiere, also dass es halt auch irgendwie albern, aber was sie am interessantesten fand einfach der Punkt, wer garantiert denn das.
Dass das, was heute noch kostenlos ist, später auch kostenlos bleiben wird. Steht da nämlich auch nicht drin. Ja, da steht derzeit drin, na ja, hier
Kommt doch mal alle zu uns und dann ist es halt irgendwie kostenlos, aber jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus. Stream on wird jetzt ein Riesenerfolg, äh alle Mobilfunknutzer in Deutschland können sich irgendwie nichts schöneres mehr vorstellen, als an diesem Tarif teilzunehmen
was natürlich
vielleicht nicht gerade zu einer Monopolstellung äh führt, aber dann doch zumindest äh die Chance hätte, Marktbeherrschend oder zumindest stark Einflussnehmend zu sein und äh ja, was ist, wenn dann die Telekom sagt, naja, ab jetzt kostet das Geld.
Und dass dann sozusagen schon so einen Status hat
wo dann die Leute sagen, na ja, wenn ich euch nicht kostenlos über meinen Tarif abrufen kann, dann dann äh suche ich mir halt einen anderen Dienst. Und das ist genau der Effekt, den wir immer kritisiert haben. Ähm äh mangelnder Netzneutralität,
Und deswegen ist halt dieser Dienst eine Gefahr. Nach wie vor ähm wie gesagt, schöne Diskussionen,
und so, die unsere Diskussion abrundet. Sollte es noch Unternehmen geben, die.
Ähnliche Vorbehalte zu formulieren, auch öffentlich zu formulieren in der Lage und bereit sind,
Ein paar gab's ja schon. Ähm Thomas Loninger.
Freut sich äh sehr über ein entsprechendes Feedback, weil er halt gerade versucht alles in die Wege zu leiten, um dieser
diesen Vertrag noch einen Riegel vorzuschieben durch entsprechende Beschwerde bei der Bundesnetzagentur. Ähm, ja, dann setzt euch einfach mit ihm in Verbindung.
Unter äh.
Epic Setter Works.
Oder sollen wir jetzt hier seine E-M.
Namensumstellung. Nein, das ähm muss ja erstmal. Langsam äh sich äh anpassen. Wir sind ja schon alt.
Ja, so eine Namensänderung erfordert halt auch einfach Digitalcourage.
Ähm die äh der Staatstrojaner wird äh ausgeweitet.
Oh, schön, dass es äh.
Wir haben.
Sauf da, da haben doch alle da haben doch alle drauf gewartet.
Also ich muss echt mal sagen wie macht das jetzt hier seit ich weiß nicht genau seit wie vielen Jahren ich mich wirklich einfach täglich mit Netzpolitik auseinandersetze.
Und ich letzte Woche habe ich mit mich mit jemandem aus dem Club irgendwie ein bisschen darüber unterhalten, was irgendwie gerade so passiert und.
Es ist, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal so, dass ich wirklich Probleme habe, noch alle Fäden in der Hand zu halten. Was so gerade alles abgeht,
Weil es gera.
Inhaltlich folgen zu können, weißt du.
Ja also genau, bei jedem bei jedem Trainer irgendwie so den genauen, die genaue Anzahl der Verletzten zu kennen, ja? So, das, es ist jetzt wirklich einfach so, das ist also Staatstrojaner.
Mal die die Zeiten.
Haben wir ja jetzt gerade.
Master sind.
Wir haben den ja wir haben also der es sind einfach so viele Baustellen gerade, ne? Also wir haben den den Staatstrojaner ja gerade erst wieder bekommen,
Nach der äh BKA-Gesetzgeschichte. So und das Entscheidende Argument war oder der entscheidende Punkt beim Staatstrainer war ja okay,
der Grundrechtseingriff ist enorm,
ja? Und das dann gesagt wurde, na gut, ja das stimmt, aber ne, es kann ja nicht sein, dass hier äh die Terroristen einfach äh ne mit Hilfe von verschlüsselter Kommunikation sich der der Überwachung entziehen.
Und deswegen machen erlauben wir für die schwere, für schwere Straftaten und äh so dann diese.
Diese Ermittlungsmethode der Online-Durchsuchung und der Quellen TKÜ Online-Durchsuchung, dein Computer wird vollständig durchsucht. Quellen TKÜ, deine Kommunikation, die du mit dem oder es wird versucht nur deine Kommunikation abzuhören.
Und ähm jetzt wird natürlich die ähm
das ist klar, dass so etwas ausgewertet wird, ausgeweitet werden muss, weil es ja eine Begrenzung, ne? So und das heißt, jetzt haben sie gerade die STPO-Novelle äh im am Gange und sagen, na okay ähm.
Jetzt weiten wir die Quellen TKÜ aus,
alle achtunddreißig Straftaten, bei denen Ermittlungsbehörden bisher auch die normale Telekommunikationsüberwachung durchführen können. Vorher war das, waren das sehr viel weniger
Straftaten
Ja, also das heißt, sie dürfen dann ab jetzt ähm bei diesen achtunddreißig Straftaten auch in Computer und Smartphones einbrechen, um eine Quellen-TKÜ durchzuführen und im Jahr zweitausendfünfzehn.
Kam diese äh TKÜ in fast ähm,
sechstausend Verfahren zum Einsatz und in deren Rahmen wurde wurden zweiunddreißigtausend solcher Anordnungen durchgeführt, ja? Die Hälfte davon wegen äh Drogen,
Ja, also Drogen ist ja offenbar immer noch unser größtes Problem in der heutigen Zeit, ne? Äh Drogenkriminalität, Drogen, Handel, ähm Import, Export und ähm.
So wie.
Jetzt haben wir, weißt du, jahrelang kämpfst du dafür, dann drücken sie dir das irgendwie. Ja, ja, aber nur, weil schwerster Kriminalität, Terror, Proliferation, Nuklearwaffenschmuggel, hier so ein Scheiß, ne? Und dann zack ist es am Ende eben doch nur eine Zeile in der ähm,
in so einer SDP-Onovelle, wo du schnell sagst, alles klar und jetzt einfach mal kurz bei für alles. Ähm es wird der äh Richtervorbehalt weiterhin gelten.
Aber ähm,
Ne? Ich meine, man sieht ja, wir haben uns da auch über diesen Richter vorbehalt. Ja, oft genug unterhalten und wenn man überlegt, dass irgendwie zweiunddreißigtausend TKÜ-Anordnungen, zweitausendfünfzehn
stattgefunden haben, weiß ich nicht wie viele hunderte bis tausende Funkzellen abfragen, das ist immer nur ein Vordruck, den der Richter schnell.
Ja, also die Richter gibt's gar nicht, die sich darum ausreichend kümmern könnten.
Also es ist einfach mal wieder so ein so ein Wortbruch, ne? Schwerste Kriminalität, die wird die ganze Zeit Angst gemacht mit Terror,
Die haben den Trojaner noch nicht fertig, dann wird der ganze Mist ausgeweitet ähm auf äh auf im Prinzip,
Alltagskriminalität. Naja, irgendwie auf Twitter habe ich dann da, also Andre hatte das, ich habe den André hatte das veröffentlicht als allererstes, diesen.
Diesem Gesetzesentwurf. Wir hatten vorher schon die den Änderungsantrag von CDU und SPD da gesehen. Ähm.
Und dann beschwert sich jemand, ja, was ist das für eine normale Alltagskriminalität, eine Bagatellisierung, ne? Ja, aber es ist halt eine Bagatellisierung, wenn der, wenn der Grundrechtseingriff so,
so so radikal ist, ne? Also schießt er jetzt wirklich mit Kanonen auf Spatzen und das Problem, wenn du es auf diese einfachen.
Delikte herunterfährst, ist eben auch, dass die, dass man die Diät natürlich sehr viel leichter andichten kann, ja? Das heißt, du landest einfach schneller,
in dieser Sache, ja? Bevor, wenn jetzt jemand mich mit dem Staatstrianer überwachen möchte, dann müsste er mir halt erstmal nachweisen, äh welche Verstrickung ich mit den, mit den internationalen Terrorismus habe, ja,
Aber ein Ladendiebstahl oder sowas, da das ist halt eine sehr viel niedrigschwelligere Anschuldigung auch, ja? Da laden die so daher gesagt, eine Drogenkriminalität. Ist sehr niedrig, schwellige äh eine eine sehr niedrigschwellige Anschuldigung,
wo du relativ einfachen Anfangsverdacht haben, herbeidichtend konstruieren kannst und entsprechend hast du dann eben bei den,
Strafverfolgungsbehörden freie Hand und natürlich auch ähm sag ich mal wenn du das politisch einsetzen möchtest dieses freie Hand, ja? Man ist ja auch immer überlegen, wem es geht ja nicht darum sind jetzt die die Polizisten heute nett,
sondern es geht darum in welchen politischen Verhältnissen leben wir morgen und möchten wir da äh einen derartigen Vertrauens,
Vorschuss geben. Spannenderweise das Ganze wird dann auch noch
in der One Acryl-Woche äh äh kommt es an die Öffentlichkeit, ne? Daran gearbeitet haben sie natürlich vorher, aber wir beklagen gerade so einen großen Follow des Fehlers staatlichen Hackings.
Und die sagen, yeah, geil, ey, das, das wollen wir auch.
Das war äh das kann einfach nicht sein, ne. Da wenn die NSA hier die die Welt äh in Schutt und Asche legen kann, dass sie das nicht können.
Woher kommt's? Ja, dreimal dürft ihr raten, aus welchem Ministerium wohl die Novelle der Strafprozessordnung kommt.
Heiko Maas.
Dein neuer Freund.
Neuer äh jemand mit dem ich mich unterhielt ähm bezeichnete wie wie war das,
Genau, der der bezeichnete Heiko Maas als ein Sonntagsredner
Und zwar ist ihm aufgefallen, dass der in unterschiedlichen Kontexten, egal, je nachdem, auf welcher Bühne er steht, eben eine andere Fahne hochhält, ja. Und ein Mensch, der sehr davon getrieben zu sein scheint, dass ihm die Mehrheit der Menschen
zustimmt, ja? Und das ist auch nicht das jetzt auch keine kein charakterlicher Vorwurf, denn so wollen wir unsere Politiker ja auch haben
auf eine gewisse Weise. Ja ich meine du du willst ja ähm.
Ne, die du willst Politiker haben, die ihr Fähnchen schön in den Wind halten und die ganze Zeit den Druck der kommenden Wahl spüren, damit sie den Kontakt zu dem
zu der Bevölkerung, die sie regieren nicht verlieren, ja? Aber ähm! Es
Du kannst eben das auch nur so weit machen. Du musst ja auch irgendwie deine eigene Marke als Politiker schärfen und irgendwas zeigen, für das du einstehst. Und das, was der Heiko Maas macht, ist halt,
einfach sorry, so, so kannst du das eben nicht machen,
so dass es ein ähm ein Opportunist und ähm eben zu sehr davor zu viel davon,
jemand dem wo du am Ende weißt, dem kannst du einfach mit nichts, was dir sagt, vertrauen. Und zwar egal ähm in welche Richtung er sich bewegen möchte,
Und äh das Schlimme ist, dass der wahrscheinlich, also ich meine, die, dass die Karriere zieht. Der letzte der letzte, der so drauf war übrigens, ne, wenn ich das mal so vorsichtig,
keine keine falschen historischen Vergleiche ziehen, ne? Aber weißt du wer auch so drauf war? Karl Theodor von uns zu Gutenberg, das war genauso ein Kaliber.
Also mal gucken, ob der Heiko Maas irgendwo noch so eine Doktorarbeit rumfliegen hat.
Silberdoktor.
Weiß ich nicht, aber Sänger war der, hast du gesehen? Der hat irgend so einen FC Köln Lied gesungen oder? Ja, ja.
Ernsthaft? Wow.
Gestern auf Twitter haben wir vorbeigekommen, aber okay, kommen wir. Eins, zwei, jung waren, haben wir alle mal an der falschen Stelle gesungen. Ja, aber wir haben ja noch sehr, noch sehr viel, wir haben ja noch sehr viel mehr ähm List, also wir müssen heute den heute ist ja wirklich eine der dichtesten Mistwochen.
Ich glaube, das ist kein Doktor.
Na ja, SPD, Malucha, ne?
Ja, ja, genau. Ja, ja. Kumpel und.
Von der von der Kohle noch das schwarze Gesicht.
Ja, ja, der sieht schon aus wie so ein Malocher. Da sieht man auch immer, wie viel Mühe der sich gibt bei seiner Arbeit, echt solide
dem fällt doch äh in seinem Ministerium, um um vier der Bleistift aus der Hand. Okay, weiter geht's hier. Ähm denn wir haben noch eine ganze Menge äh eine ganze Menge lustige, schlechte Neuigkeiten für euch.
Genau, unter anderem wurde nämlich das ID Gesetz beschlossen, das,
mir hier glaube ich auch schon angekündigt. Ähm
gegen die Stimmen von Grünen und Linken hat die große Koalition das mal durchgesetzt, äh was bedeutet das? Das bedeutet, dass der Personalausweis, der ja
Bisher schon die Möglichkeit gehabt hat, eine sogenannte Online-Funktion aufzuweisen, diese künftig bei Defold auch aktiviert bekommt.
Deutet, dass man den Personalausweis benutzen kann
um sich mit äh in Kombination mit einem entsprechenden Lesegerät und Software gegenüber Behörden und einzelnen anderen äh Identitäten theoretisch, online als man selbst ausweisen kann oder zumindest aus
ausweisen kann, dass man sagt man diesen Person in der Hand hält, ne. Und ähm ja.
Das ist aber nur das eine, das andere ist, dass die darin enthaltenen Informationen äh auch äh einer größeren Zahl von Sicherheitsbehörden in den Zugriff äh,
gerückt werden sollen, nämlich Geheimdienste, Steuer und Zollfahndungen sind hier mit im Boot.
Sieht so aus, als ob zumindest ein wenig äh die Empfehlung der Datenschützer hier noch mit aufgegriffen wurden, bevor das Gesetz äh verabschiedet wurde,
Ähm vorher war es ja so gedacht, dass die,
dass dieser Zugriff einfach so erfolgen kann, ohne dass es da irgendeine Meldepflicht äh gibt, so dass man so, ja, nach dem Motto Daten, da haben wir ja, greifen wir einfach mal drauf zu, weil dafür sind die Daten ja da
Jetzt ist es so, dass die Meldeämter äh verpflichtet werden,
die Nutzer oder Eigentümer oder der Eigentümer ist man ja nicht, ne? Wenn man Personalausweis hat, gehört ja dem Staat, ne? Also.
Du musst den bezahlen.
Was man zu, wenn man darf bezahlen, aber man man ohnt die noch nicht mal. Also man man erhält die den zugeteilt und wenn dieser IT-Funktion aktiviert ist, dann soll man darauf zumindest hingewiesen werden, dass dem so sei
und man wird noch darauf hingewiesen, dass man äh,
man sollte sozusagen noch unterrichtet werden darüber, dass man eben bestimmte Sicherheitsvorkehrungen auch ähm,
berücksichtigen sollte und man wird auch noch auf die Möglichkeit der Sperrung dieser Funktion hingewiesen. Ähm ja.
Außerdem muss äh wie ist das bei der Vergabe der Berechtigungszertifikate.
Das verstehe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht hier diesen Punkt.
Ja, die Berechtigungszertifikate sind äh nicht für die Person, sondern für die Leute, die Leser betreiben. Also wenn du äh.
Okay, also darum geht's.
Ähm.
Also wenn so ein so ein Lesegerät ähm einen Personalausweis auslesen will, muss es natürlich auch entsprechend sich ähm.
Genau. Also, dass das.
Mit diesem Zertifikat weist das Lesegerät seine Berechtigung gegenüber dem dem der EID aus, dass es sie auslesen darf,
Ja? Und das ist also einfach also ein klassisches Zertifikat. Und wenn du so eins haben möchtest, damit du Personalausweise aus äh lesen kannst, ja, dann.
Dann musst du versichern.
Ja? Mittels Unterschrift auf einem Formular, ja, dass du den betrieblichen Datenschutz,
einhältst und weiterhin musst du den Zweck für die Nutzung der EID angeben auf diesem Formular, ja? Also.
Ganz har.
Das sind also da werden die ganz harten Daumenschrauben angezogen. Ich werde das mal machen.
Muss man auch nachweisen, dass man irgendwie sein Zertifikat äh äh Schlüssel auch in einem ordentlichen Tresor verwahrt und da eine Zugriffsmethode hat und äh wie man vorgeht, wenn der verloren.
Wird ja einmal provisioniert auf das Gerät. Aber ich werde ich, also ich ich versichere, dass ich den äh betrieblichen Datenschutz des der des Unternehmens Linus Neumann einhalte.
Der Zweck für die Nutzung der EID ist ausprobieren.
Oh Marken.
Ja total. Also aber das Schöne ist, ja genau, al,
da, ne? Wir hatten ja noch die Stellungnahme dazu geschrieben und zack durch den Bundestag durch, gib ihm so, ne? Wer war dafür.
Ich glaube, das kann man auch von Heiko Maas, ey, ja klar muss er. Okay, ich werde jetzt so lange auf dem rumhacken, bis ähm.
Dement haben wir noch nicht, wer hat uns verraten gesungen?
So, aber was war das, was war das Hauptproblem, ne? Ähm nebenbei ja noch diese riesige äh Biometriedatenbank. Mhm. Aber zum Glück bleibt die ja in Deutschland,
Das ist ja, ist fürchterlich, dass wir jetzt eine Satz für nationale Biometriedatenbank haben und es einen massenhaften Zugriff auf diese Passfotos geben kann, ja? Aber ähm zum Glück äh nur in Deutschland.
Sagten auch nächstes Thema Tim.
Die europäische, die europäische Kommission fand das dann irgendwie auch geil,
Und der fiel dann irgendwie auf, na ja, also jetzt hier so viele neue Datenbanken haben und die alle so äh schöne Kürzel tragen, da ist es doch, da kann es doch nicht sein, dass es so schwierig ist, all diese Informationen, die ohnehin schon da sind, auch wirklich in irgendeiner Form zu nutzen. Das ist immer so ein schönes Schema, ne
irgendjemand kommt so mit dem Vorschlag, lass uns auch mal eine neue Datenbank über das und das einrichten
dann kommt so der Widerstand und dann so, ja okay, aber das ist ja eine ganz separate Datenbank und die ist ja auch getrennt und da ist ja der Datenschutz dazwischen und gucke mal, das wird ja gar nicht zentral gespeichert. Na ja, vergeht so ein bisschen die Zeit.
Da kommt irgendwann so dieses Argument. Ach, das ist ja aber auch alles mal total ineffizient und überhaupt eine Terror. Wir können ja gar nichts tun. Äh wir müssen das jetzt mal zusammenwerfen
Und das zeichnet sie sich ja auf EU-Ebene schon länger ab. Wir hatten ja hier auch mit ähm hier sind auch gleich unser äh Gast, der so spezialisiert war auf die
europäische äh Datenbank Situation und Überwachungssituation.
Matthias Moneroy.
Genau, Matthias Monroy
da hatten wir das schon mal vorgestellt, was es denn überhaupt alles so für geile Systeme gibt so auf europäischer Ebene, damit hat man ja selten was zu tun. Na und auch genau diese ganzen sollen nun zusammengefasst werden. Laut der Kommission,
in ein europäisches Suchportal für alle Datenbanken. Und das soll dann wiederum auch noch äh durch ein gemeinsames System zum Abgleich biometrischer Daten ergänzt werden, wo man schon mal dabei ist.
Und äh die äh EU-Lisa, das ist eine Agentur auf europäischer Ebene, die sie das äh bisher halt alles betreibt, deren Madats soll dann eben auch entsprechend angepasst werden,
Der Gesetzvorschlag der Kommission wird noch im Juni erwartet. Und was,
wird da jetzt alles drin kombiniert, da kommt dann rein. Das Schengener Informationssystem. SIS. Das Visa-Informationssystem, VIS,
die Fingerabdruckdatenbank Eurodak. Das Europol-Informationssystem, also der Polizeiverbund in Europa.
Dann das europäische Strafregister-Informationssystem,
Also quasi alles was so zur Fahndung ähm zum äh ein Auslass von Ausländern et cetera und sozusagen in der europäischen Grenzübertritt gespeichert wird,
alle sitzen in einer Suchmaske. Außerdem ist geplant,
Ein- und Ausreisesystem zu etablieren, in dem sich Ausländer mit vier Finger abdrücken und biometrischem Gesichts,
in der EU registrieren lassen sollen. Das steckt dann vor allem dahinter, dass man halt diese doppelten Registrierungen äh verhindern äh möchte
ob das dann auch Bundeswehrsoldaten, die sich selber als Syrer ausgibt, auch äh erfasst, wissen wir nicht,
und ein Reiseinformations und Genehmigungssystem unter dem schönen Namen Ethias
zur Vorkontrolle visa freier Besucher. Dazu.
Nein, ist noch nicht vorbei. Dazu kommen, wir könnten noch kommen, äh, Biometrie und Gendaten, die mehrere EU-Länder,
den Prümervertrag untereinander austauschen sowie Flugpassagierdaten, also PNR ist ja auch schon öfter gemacht haben. Prima Vertrag.
Hast du ihn schon mal gehört.
Nee, sorry, ich sage ja ne.
Man entdeckt ja immer wieder was Neues, ne.
Also der Prima-Vertrag ist ein zwischenstaatliches Abkommen zwischen elf Mitgliedsstaaten der EU und Norwegen,
Ähm das schließt auch Deutschland äh mit ein und ja,
Es ist sozusagen auch nochmal so ein eine Teiluntergruppe der EU, die halt wiederum einen höheren Datenaustausch an der Stelle schon,
pflegen, darüber wissen wir noch nicht so sehr viel. Sprich
Alles am besten in einen Topf, Zugriffskontrolle minimieren und ja, die Missbrauchsoptionen steigern. Das scheint hier die Marschrichtung der EU-Kommission zu sein.
Aber das kriegst du irgendwie in einem in der gleichen Woche, ne? Eher dir äh Gesetz beschlossen und zack. EU machen wir ja direkt noch, ne?
Ach, da gibt es auch bestimmt noch mehr Inus.
Da geht noch was. Ja genau. Äh ein anderes Gesetz über das wir hier vor ein paar Wochen gesprochen haben war das äh gib Handy-Gesetz. Ähm GHG.
EHG.
Ne, wir äh wir erinnern uns dunkel, dass man sich überlegt hat, hey wenn hier so jemand kommt und Asyl haben will, dann könnten wir dem doch einfach mal das das Handy und alle Datenträger wegnehmen und auslesen, um darin äh nach ähm Beweisen zu suchen, dass äh die Person denn auch
Ähm also wie berechtigt ist in Deutschland, ja? Könnte ja, sonst könnte ja jeder kommen
Und äh was gäbe es da schöneres, als einfach mal den kompletten, den kompletten Datenträger auszulesen, ja? Und also Mobiltelefone und andere portable Datenträger. Wenn Asylsuchende ihre Identität nicht anderweitig nachweisen können.
Äh beschlossen wurde, dass äh dieses Gesetz dann auch vom Parlament ähm und äh Laptops, Tablets, USB-Sticks und so weiter gehört alles dazu. Ähm,
um eben Identität und Staatsangehörigkeit feststellen zu können. Die Voraussetzung dafür ist, dass die die Asylbewerbernde Person keine äh Ausweispapiere vorlegt
oder Name und Herkunft nicht anderweitig ausweisen kann,
also äh das Einzige, was was dich noch vor vorm vorm vorm Scan deiner Datentrigger, deines Handys und alle deiner Daten schützt, ist der äh ist dein Pass.
Ciao.
Könnten wir noch ein paar IP-Adressen speichern oder so, ne.
Ja. Da gab's äh auch Neuigkeiten und zwar ich glaube, das hatten wir auch schon ein, zwei Mal drauf hingewiesen äh.
Aktivist und auch Mitglied der Piraten, Patrick Breyer.
Hatte so eine Klage angestrebt in Berlin dagegen, dass Webseiten der Behörden,
auch dynamische IP-Adressen in ihren Lokfallspeichern mit dem Hinweis, dass sie sich hierbei um personenbezogene Daten handelt, die geschützt werden sollen.
Du sagst so, hatte so eine Klageangeschrift, wenn ich das richtig sehe, kämpft der seit zehn Jahren an diesem Thema. Also der ja, ja, der, also ähm Patrick Breyer, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist der jetzt gerade nicht mehr in dem.
Der ist jetzt rausgewählt worden mit dem anderen Piraten.
Leider. Der war ähm ist seit Ewigkeiten aktiv im AK Vorrat und dieses Thema IP-Adressenspeicherung verfolgt er seit. Also gefühlt zehn Jahren.
Genau, da geht's äh weiter und die derzeit anhängige äh Klage wurde halt vom Landgericht Berlin an den BGH äh weitergereicht und der BGA hat jetzt entschieden, dass dynamische IP-Adressen. Sehr wohl.
Äh als ein Personenbezogenes Datum gewertet werden können.
Und äh hat sozusagen äh Patrick Bayer hier, wie es scheint, zumindest als Zwischenetappe. Erstmal Recht gegeben. Eine Speicherung,
Über den Nutzungsvorgang sei nur erlaubt, um die generelle Funktionsfähigkeit der Dienste zu gewährleisten.
Dabei bedürfe es allerdings eine Abwägung zwischen den Interessen der Webseitenanbieter sowie den Grundrechten und Freiheiten der Nutzer,
heißt es in der Pressemitteilung des Bundesgerichtshofs,
Das Interessante ist, dass es ähm vorher ja schon eine Entscheidung gab, auf EU-Ebene vom Europäischen Gerichtshof,
Prinzip ähm das eh nicht dargestellt hat nur dass eben die Einschränkung so war, dass diese personenbezogenheit eigentlich nur dann vorliegt,
Wenn der Anbieter auch rechtliche Mittel hat, Zugriff auf diese Zuordnung zu erhalten
Das ist jetzt schon mal ganz anders aus, weil so ein normaler Webseitenbetreiber hat ja kein unmittelbaren rechtlichen Zugriff da drauf, sondern es ist sozusagen etwas, was ja erst
beantragt werden muss im Straffall et cetera, also selbst wenn ich jetzt eine dynamische IP-Adresse einsammel habe ich ja nicht automatisch 'ne Möchliche Möglichkeit mir diese Zuordnung,
zu holen und dementsprechend.
Überrascht dieses Urteil ein wenig mich zumindest und äh so oder so geht aber der Fall jetzt erstmal wieder ans Landgericht Berlin und von daher ist da der Drops noch lange nicht gelutscht, das könnte sich für ihn hier noch zu so einem
Dauerthema äh entwickeln willst, was nicht schon längst ist.
Ja weitere Inkompatibilitäten im juristischen Bereich.
Na ja, das Netz, Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz wurde, wenn ich das jetzt richtig entsinne letzten Freitag,
in erster Lesung im Bundestag gehört, also ich bin wie gesagt, es ist das erste Mal, dass ich meine Schachfiguren nicht mehr hundertprozentig unter Kontrolle habe hier.
Master schwächelt.
Ähm weil äh aber da war ich bei bei wie heißt dieser Fernsehsender von.
Muss die Hand auf den Globus legen, Lino.
Ja, ich muss die Hand auf den Glosen. Ähm der war habe ich beim anlässlich testen war ich bei N24 irgendwie habe da habe darüber gesprochen. Ähm.
Das ist jetzt glaube ich irgendwie so, wurde dann jetzt auch in Richtung des Bundestages äh hinabgereicht, um dort äh.
Vom Stimmvieh abgesegnet zu werden. Ähm es gab noch minimale,
minimale Änderung und zwar ich mein dass das Kernproblem mit dem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist ja dass diese Rechtsdurchsetzung dann eben
in privater Hand ist, also die Löschung muss von einem muss vom Unternehmen selber äh vorgenommen werden
sofort nach Prüfung innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden und wenn das Unternehmen etwas,
löscht, was es nicht löschen sollte, dann geht es straffrei und wenn es etwas,
nicht löscht, was es löschen sollte, dann drohen enorme Strafen, ja? Also das, was man einen Bayers nennt, nämlich im Zweifel
gegen den Angeklagten zu entscheiden ist hier steht hier in dem äh Gesetz drin. Jetzt sollten da Teile dessen etwas abge.
Dämpft werden, äh durch eine sogenannte oh, wie heißt das nochmal.
Also quasi ein ein eine Anordnung. Du du kannst quasi deinen Behörden noch, also das Ministerium kann den Behörden eine Anordnung geben, wie zu verfahren sei, ja? Aber die äh,
Verordnung heißt das dann glaube ich. Aber diese Verordnung, die kannst du nach nach Lust und äh äh Laune ändern.
Jederzeit und auch jeder kommende Justizminister ähm,
Kann das also jederzeit die Verordnung wieder ändern? Das heißt, die haben natürlich dann keinen keinen so bindenden Charakter wie das Gesetz und was sie geändert haben, sind ähm,
Die Begründungen des Gesetzes, die aber eben kein Gesetz Gesetzescharakter haben und eben diese Verordnung, das sind aber eben nicht die ähm.
Also das Gesetz bleibt eben dann halt Mist. Ja? Ähm entsprechend hat dann der Bitcom ähm mal ein, ein,
Gutachten in Auftrag gegeben in der Universitäts Göttingen und hat das hat dann Gerald Sprint Spindler
mal angefertigt und hat gesagt, na ja, so wie das Ding da formuliert ist, Verstöß ist gegen Europarecht, wundert einen ja jetzt nicht, dass äh ein Gesetz aus dem Hause Maas äh mehrere handwerkliche Fehler aufweist.
Ähm und zwar wird bemängelt der Verstoß gegen das Ursprungsland Prinzip. Ähm,
denn das Gesetz möchte seine drakonischen Regeln äh nicht nur äh in Deutschland durchsetzen
sondern auch in der EU und darüber hinaus, ja? Und das äh sagt er widerspricht dem Ursprungslandprinzip der E-Commerce-Richtlinie, da welches sich dort in Artikel drei befindet. Ähm und zwar erlaubt die,
E-Commerce-Richtlinie, Mitgliedsländern zwar einzelne Dienstleister gegen einzelne Dienstleister in der Gemeinschaft vorzugehen, aber nicht gegen ganze Dienstleisterklassen.
Ähm denn der jeweilige Mitgliedsstaat soll für seine Anbieter zuständig bleiben. Also, schon mal so irgendwie so die die den Artikel drei der europäischen E-Commerce-Richtlinie direkt verletzt, ne? Steht wahrscheinlich noch auf Seite eins mit drauf so, ne?
Die Löschfristen sind eindeutig zu kurz. Ähm, das ist etwas, was ich auch bei N vierundzwanzig mehrmals betont habe,
Die sagen ja, sie wollen eines vierundzwanzig Stunden Schrift. Äh äh vierundzwanzig Stunden Frist. Und ich hatte mich da auch nochmal mit Volker Trip drüber unterhalten, der mir ein schönes Beispiel dazu nannte. Nämlich war genau, was diesen Graubereich der Meinungsfreiheit angeht. Wir erinnern uns an dieses Böhmermann-Gedicht.
Darüber haben wir Monate diskutiert, das ist durch X-Distanzen gegangen, ja und quasi eine solche Entscheidung,
soll so ein Facebook Mitarbeiter ohne juristische besondere Vorbildung oder oder Aus.
Prüfung.
Die soll der dann innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden treffen, ja? Ähm und selbst in selbst wenn du vor Gericht ein Eiverfahren erreichst, ja, gibt es keine Fristdefinitionen. Wir haben in der Juristerei immer,
offenbar ähm zumindest bei so Prüfungs,
Dingern eben so viel Zeit, wie man eben braucht. Ja, also er wird jetzt nicht gesagt, die Entscheidung muss innerhalb kürzester Zeit äh getroffen werden, auch in einem Eilverfahren kriegst du nicht eine definitiv definierte Frist
Klar, du kriegst einmal, wenn du antworten musst oder sowas, ne, aber eine rechtliche Prüfung ähm durch durch die Justiz unterliegt, keiner.
Per se diff im im Gesetz definierten Frist und erst recht nicht einer von vierundzwanzig Stunden. Und in diesen vierundzwanzig Stunden muss er nicht nur geprüft werden, sondern auch äh ähm
Also die zwischen
Beschwerde, dann Kenntnis, dann dann äh ähm Illegalität der Löschung, ne, dass er als in vierundzwanzig Stunden erledigt werden. Also es geht einfach gar nicht.
Und äh dann sagt er natürlich auch und das ist etwas, was wir im Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ähm in letzter Zeit gar nicht mehr so richtig äh betont haben
Wir haben ja hier eine Datenherausgabe ohne Richtervorbehalt, als wir das Thema zum ersten Mal besprochen haben, habe ich darauf hingewiesen, dass das natürlich auch nochmal in Richtung ähm
Abmahnindustrie ein Geschenk ist
Richtung was weiß ich, ne, du hast irgendwie ein Bewertungs in so einem Bewertungsportal, weil das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ja auch für irgendwie den Schutz deiner Markenrechte und so weiter gilt, ne,
Also der Beispiel, den wir da hatten war, du schreibst irgendwie eine eine negative Bewertung über eine Produkt oder eine Arztpraxis und die sagen nö, da dadurch wird ja unsere Arztpraxis verunglimpft,
Das geht ja wohl mal überhaupt nicht. Das ist schlecht fürs Geschäft. Wir wollen wissen, wer das ist,
und dann sagt er eben, der Widerspruch zur neuen Datenschutzgrundverordnung der EU, der hier äh äh erkenntlich ist, denn ähm.
Dass Beschwerdeführer von den Diensteanbietern ganz ohne richterlichen Beschluss die Daten der Nutzer herausverlangen können passt,
gar nicht zu den jüngsten Ermahnungen der europäischen Gerichte im Bezug auf den Zugang
Vorratsdaten selbst die Durchsetzungsrichtlinie, die Durchsetzungsrichtlinie, die Urheberrechtsinhabern zuliebe in der EU verabschiedet wurde, verlangt den Richter Vorbehalt
der ist den den Experten von Heiko Maas hier entgangen und das also es ist wirklich meine Güte, was willst du denn da noch.
Was willst du denn da noch irgendwie? Was willst denn da noch schönes? Sollen wir mal was Schönes sagen.
Vielleicht kommt er nicht in den Knast dafür.
Der Heiko Maas nicht in den Knast. Meinst du?
Nee. Wenn's gut läuft, Heiko? Wenn's gut läuft. Wirst du, wirst du, wirst du nicht impeacht.
Wenn's gut läuft, kriegst du, kriegst du. Wenn sie, wenn's gut läuft, kriegst du die Juristen, die Justiz in Deutschland noch schnell genug ruiniert, als dass sie dir noch irgendwann mal was anhaben könnte. Nein, blöder Witz.
Aber ich glaube selbst wenn es bei der Bundestagswahl gut läuft. Ich weiß nicht, ob da wirklich so die die Karriere im Justizministerium fortgesetzt werden sollte.
Wie wie nennt man das äh hieß Innet for the Long Game oder so was? Der ist doch Karrierist, der wird doch nicht, der will doch nicht etwas Justiz.
Bundeskanzler werden.
Ja, natürlich, wer will das werden? Klar.
Bundeskanzlerin werden. Na ja.
Alle kleine emanuel Macrons jetzt.
Chelsea Mening ist frei, gute Nachrichten, yay.
Ja sehr viel mehr weiß man aber auch nicht, ne? Doch. Was? Gibt's.
Doch. Na, sie hat ein Selfie gepostet und ein äh und ein Foto ähm wie sie am Wochenende irgendwie mit der Spielkonsole zockt mit ihren Gruppels oder mit ihren Freunden. Also.
Weiß ich nicht, Autorennen. Ja, ist doch s.
Okay. Ja. Selfie habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ja, müssen wir gucken.
Ähm ja, ist siebzehnter Mai war das, glaube ich, dass äh das Datum der Freilassung, ne? Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, ist äh sie läuft,
frei, hat irgendwie ein Foto von ihren Füßen mit den ersten Schritten in Freiheit gemacht.
Das habe ich gesehen.
Ja dann irgendwie ein paar Tage, paar Stunden später ein Selfie und dann nochmal irgendwie in Intendo gezockt. Super, alles Gute.
Erhol dich von dem ganzen Scheiß und Start hinein, schönes neues Leben, ich glaub viel mehr braucht man da gar nicht zu zu sagen.
Ne, ich glaube auch äh man sollte nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass jetzt äh sofort auf tausend Kongressen äh et cetera.
Ich würde es mir,
würde es mir natürlich wünschen, dass wir sie im Dezember, äh dass wir unser Ehrenmitglied im Dezember äh begrüßen können, aber ich glaube, äh sie hat echt gerade nochmal einen ganz anderen,
Hut von Dingen zu verarbeiten und das muss sie selber wissen, was sie wie sie das Leben jetzt gestaltet,
Hoffentlich stehen dir ja genug Wege dafür offen.
Thanks obama.
Tja, auch ein bisschen frei ist äh unser Freund Juri Asanchov. Ähm.
Der ist ja nun seit Jahren wie lange jetzt schon? Fünf, vier, fünf. Ewig. In.
Der Botschaft der Äquadorianischen Botschaft in London ja quasi im Fluchtzustand,
Nachdem er ja vorher auch schon,
Hausarrest hat. Ich glaube, das ist auch etwas, was äh viele Leute äh übersehen. Also er war ja schon festgesetzt. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob das wegen derselben Geschichte war. Ich vermute ja, wegen dieser
Anklage aus.
Ja ja wegen des wegen des Laufen wegen der Ermittlung, dass er sich nicht im äh also da ging es ja quasi dann um die Auslieferung. Das war übrigens äh ich sehe das gerade LNP neunundzwanzig mit dem wunderschönen Titel, einmal Asyl und eine Flexbitte.
Vom zweiundzwanzigsten Juni zweitausendzwölf. Also der ist jetzt ziemlich der ist jetzt ziemlich bald ist er dann ungefähr fünf Jahre sitzt er in dieser und das sind glaube ich nur zwei Raumwohnungen da, ne? Äh die,
Egwadorianische B.
Die sind auch ganz froh, wenn sie mal wieder äh anders untervermieten können. Ähm sicherlich keine Freude, keine Ahnung, ob sie sich noch zusätzlich andere äh Räumlichkeiten gesucht haben und dieser Ort nur noch existiert, um i.
Das kann ja auch gut sein.
Boah neunundzwanzig krass.
Ja, ja, das ist echt lange her.
Zweihundert Sendungen ist das her. Wahnsinn.
Aber immerhin hat er schöne Sendungen hören können.
Hat uns auf jeden Fall ordentliche Titel äh gebracht. So oder so.
Die Ermittlungen in Schweden wurden also nun eingestellt, das ließ sich wohl auch nicht mehr länger halten. Dementsprechend ist auch der damit einhergehende europäische Haftbefehl
aufgehoben worden
Sodass man jetzt sagen könnte, na ja, jetzt liegt ja eigentlich nichts mehr gegen ihn vor, zumindest liegt nicht mehr das vor, was ihnen ursprünglich in diesen Haushalts gebracht hat und was ihn in diese Botschaft hineingetrieben hat
Man könnte jetzt denken, so, na ja, warum geht der denn da nicht raus aus seiner Botschaft? Na ja, nun wissen wir ja, dass,
Großbritannien und die USA ist immer schon sehr geil fanden auf ihrer Special Relationship äh herumzuturnen. Nun wissen wir auch, dass äh UK in der Zwischenzeit halt äh ganz andere Pfade einge
Und okay, im Wesentlichen extrem auch Verbündete angewiesen ist. Insbesondere verbündet die so in den nächsten Jahren
Handelsbeziehungen mit ihnen äh eingehen sollen so und das natürlich gerade mit einem Trump, der irgendwie auf von so internationalen
Handelsverträgen ohnehin nicht viel hält, äh, gar nicht so einfach, da lege es doch sehr nahe
wenn man seinen großen Bruder da mal ein Geschenk vor die äh Haustür legt und dann würde sich ja dann hier Assanchof auch.
Anbieten, auch wenn ich so ganz klar ist, wer jetzt eigentlich irgendwie seine Aktivitäten der letzten Zeit so richtig geil findet oder nicht
ne? Weil das ja äh zumindest eine Rolle gespielt hat in diesem ganzen äh in diesem ganzen äh Datenattacken, die,
auf
die demokratische Partei im Rahmen des Wahlkampfs gefahren wurde, das steht sicherlich außer Zweifel, auch wenn ich weiter von entfernt bin, hier Fingerpointing zu betreiben und zu sagen, die und die Person hat das und das gemacht.
Nur die ganze Zeit Juria Sunchow, aber sonst machen wir keine Spekulation.
Ich meine, der war ja bei RT im Fernsehen und so weiter. Also es äh ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass er sich diesen Namen nicht selber verdient hätte.
War ich aber auch schon mal.
Nur ein bisschen lieber Holion nennen.
Ähm.
Mal gucken, welchem Land der sich als nächstes äh zu äh wendet. Also Jubel möchte jetzt auf jeden Fall zurückklagen,
weil das ja alles nicht okay war. Wir werden sehen, wofür hier noch Geld rausgegeben wird. Äh es bleibt spannend.
Name, also die Frage ist ja.
Ähm also erstens die Anklägerin Marianne sagte einfach so, wir sehen keine Möglichkeit, die Ermittlungen weiter voranzubringen. Äh wir treffen keine Aussagen zur Schuld und stellen die jetzt eben ein, ne? Ähm.
Mit anderen Worten so ein ähm Einstellung des Verfahrens aus Mangel an Beweisen, äh nennt man ja so ein bisschen so den.
Freispruch, zweiter Klasse.
Zwei Sprachen Freispruch zweiter Klasse, ne? Ähm.
Reicht ihm, glaube ich.
Es stellt sich natürlich echt die Frage, warum warum die fünf Jahre dafür gebraucht haben.
Es gab da ja irgendwie diesen Hickhack mit der Befragung und wer dann da ist und ob da ein Botschaft und und was da alles für ein Theater war ähm.
Aber das ist jetzt die Situation. Jetzt ist der ähm jetzt hingehen, aber nur mal fünf Jahre in dieser Botschaft rum und da stand die fünf Jahre jeden Tag und jede Nacht und vollständig ein Polizist vor der Tür. Ja, um ihn,
sollte er sich aus diesem Haus bewegen wollen, dort dann entsprechend direkt in Empfang zu nehmen.
Ähm da durch die Einstellung des Verfahrens ist natürlich jetzt auch das Auslieferungsgesuch und der europäische Haftbefehl oder was auch immer Schweden da alles angestrengt hat. Hinfällig,
und man würde erwarten, dass der gute Mann, der da vor der Tür steht, jetzt äh nach Hause geht und oder zur Wache geht und sagt
Wo soll ich mich jetzt hinstellen? Ja und ähm äh das passiert aber wohl nicht, denn Scott Land Yard gab dann bekannt, na ja ähm,
Er wurde wegen einem schweren Vergehen gesucht und entsprechend haben wir da gelauert. Ähm.
Er wird aber weiterhin wegen eines nicht mehr so schweren Vergehens gesucht.
Weil er gegen nämlich seine Hausarbeitsbedingungen verstoßen hat.
So und da war's, da weiß ich nämlich noch, dass ich äh in der NMP neunundzwanzig, nämlich gesagt habe, so, na ja, kannst ja auch nicht aus dem Knast ausbrechen und dann einfach erwarten, dass dass du keine äh keine Verlängerung, deine,
Wer eines Urteils kriegt oder irgendeine Form von Strafen, da wurde ich nämlich belehrt. Das ist zumindest in Deutschland so ist, dass dir der eine allgemeine Freiheitsdrang.
Zugestanden wird und du für Fluchtversuche
nicht bestraft wirst, solange du nicht zwischendurch noch irgendwie fünf Werte erschießt oder sowas, ne? Und dann also für den reinen Fluchtversuch mit einer Nagelfeile oder sowas wirst du keine,
keine juristische Strafe bekommen, wird's wahrscheinlich also kommt, kommst du wahrscheinlich dann in irgendwelche verschärfte Haftbedingungen, aber du wirst nicht länger da sitzen. Wirst nicht verurteilt wegen Gefängnisausbru,
wurde ich belehrt und jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, wie ist das in Großbritannien und wie ist das vor allem bei diesen Fußfesseln,
denn da könnte man ja auch äh juristisch argumentieren. Naja, der hat gegen eine Auflage verstoßen und selbstverständlich ist das strafbewährt. Äh sich gegen,
sich dieser Auflage zu widersetzen, muss es ja sein, sonst würden die Leute mit ihren Fußfesseln ja rumlaufen, wie sie wollen.
Also weiß ich, weiß ich einfach tatsächlich nicht, wie ähm.
Die britische Justiz jetzt mit diesem Fall umgehen wird, so oder so wird der sich aber nicht in eine Situation begeben, wo er in eine britische Verwahrung kommt, weil er damit rechnen könnte,
Das in dem Moment, wo der irgendwo in Urhaft in Großbritannien sitzt, irgendjemand in äh USA, in die Schublade äh greift und sagt, ah,
Ganz vergessen, die Anklageschrift gegen Assange und hier äh Auslieferungsgesuch im Eilverfahren an Großbritannien, Wuppiduu. So und wenn ihr den eh gerade mal im Knast habt, könnt ihr den doch direkt dadrin sitzen lassen und äh wir kommen, wir kommen.
Kein Problem, wir holen den ab, ist echt wir zahlen auch,
Wir zahlen auch das Mittagessen noch für den.
Ja, also das wird sicherlich jetzt nicht äh einfach und ich glaube auch nicht, dass äh UK da äh ein besonders verlässlicher Partner ist, insbesondere, wo sie ja jetzt äh so darauf bedacht sind, den,
Boden der EU zu verlassen und insbesondere haben wir ja so Menschen, Gerichtshof et cetera Menschenrechts.
Wie heißt das Ding? Europäischer Gerichtshof Menschenrechte.
Wie Gmer.
Das finde ich ja gar nicht gut. Also so Menschenrechte.
Menschenrechtsgerichtshöfe haben die haben die Amis eh nicht so mit zu.
Nein, die Briten auch. Also die Briten finden das äh wird das wird da offen diskutiert, da äh da wollen sie einfach mal komplett raus aus diesen ganzen Abhängig.
Ist auch ehrgeizig.
Ja ja als äh stört ja einfach nur und dann kennen wir ja auch die
Verschärfung der Gesetze, also allein mit so bloßem Terrorverdacht kann man halt auch einfach schon mal so zwei Wochen festgehalten werden. Wir hatten das ja dann mit der Durchreise von Niranda dem äh Lebenspartner von Glen Green Wold. Also,
Ich denke aus seiner Position heraus ist Skepsis sehr wohl äh angebracht und ich frage mich halt andererseits auch
nicht irgendjemanden in Europa, der sich jetzt äh für ihn groß in die Bresche werfen würde, um ihn da sozusagen, um den Briten irgendetwas und ein Zugeständnis abzu,
Verlangen.
Und in der Sanche ist daraus? Nee. Nee, also ich glaube die einzige Chance, die der hat, ist bei ähm.
Bei Nacht und Nebel irgendwie zu gucken, dass er aus dem Land rauskommt,
die Equadorianer wollen sich ja dann auch für sicheres Geleit werden im Rahmen ihrer diplomatischen,
dann wird der,
Antrag wird wahrscheinlich dann infinitypending sein. Er wird da so schnell nicht rauskommen, wobei er ja sagte, so, wenn ob also da darf man,
gleich ein bisschen gemein, aber für den Assange twitterte er eines nachts ähm dass wenn wenn äh Chelsea Menning frei kommt, er auch,
sich den Behörden stellt, so jetzt wäre eine gute Gelegenheit, aber äh dass er das nicht machen wird, ist natürlich auch klar. Der twittert auch manchmal ein bisschen zu viel,
wie wir alle. Insofern sehen wir es ihm nach.
Und äh kommt besten Präsidenten vor.
Den besten Präsidenten. Ja, ja. Ähm.
Dann haben wir noch, also ich glaube nicht, dass da jetzt so schnell was passieren wird bei beim Asanches.
Was haben wir denn noch an Themen? Ja, genau, ach so, ist auch sehr schön. Das äh die die Löschregeln von Facebook sind geliegt.
Und das sind irgendwie insgesamt tausend Seiten. Ja, also aber jetzt nicht alles beschriebene beschriebene Papiere, sondern auch so PowerPoint-Folien und so, ne.
Und ähm.
Facebook hatte ja schon irgendwie Anfang des Monats gesagt, dass sie weltweit dreitausend neue Online-Aufpasser einstellen wollen, ne? Andere nennen so nennen diese Menschen Zensoren,
Sie haben bisher viereinhalbtausend,
ja? Ähm Themen, die wir hier nicht behandelt haben, sind unter anderem, dass es ja jetzt mehrere Male äh schwerisch, also Dokumentationen schwerer Straftaten in im Rahmen von,
so Facebook äh Videos gab, ne? Facebook live oder wie das dann heißt. Also einmal,
glaube ich, ja, Morde, Vergewaltigung und so, wo das wo die Leute halt irgendwie für.
Ich weiß, also das ist auch so ein Phänomen, was ich mir nicht so ganz entschließt, äh erschließt. Und.
Ähm Facebook ist da irgendwie massiv in der Kritik und sagen also jetzt so in Reaktion darauf wollen sie ohnehin äh ne von viereinhalbtausend äh Mitarbeitern weltweit auf siebeneinhalbtausend Mitarbeiter weltweit gehen. Die ähm.
Eben Inhalte aus Facebook herauslöschen. Und ähm interessant ist, ähm die müssen das im Schnitt innerhalb von zehn Sekunden machen.
Nimm dies Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz so. Die die zittern schon wie Espenlaub äh wenn jetzt irgendwie äh Heiko Maas kommt, ne? Also meine Güte. Ähm,
Und das ist sehr interessant, weil die natürlich eine sehr, also sie müssen halt diese,
diese, also wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen sich deren Situationen vorstellt, die müssen halt eine klare Linie definieren und müssen immer gleich entscheiden. Und das heißt, in diesen Dokumenten findet sich eben das, was sie ähm.
Al
Die Grenze der Meinungsfreiheit definiert haben und zwar über Jahre der Erfahrung. Das wird jetzt irgendwie, wurde vom über den Guardien gelegt und irgendwie sehr weit ausgebreitet und dann wird jetzt auch irgendwie natürlich viel drüber gelacht, weil es da irgendwelche Widersprüche drin gibt, zum Beispiel,
Lasst uns dicke Kinder schlagen, ist okay. Äh jemand sollte Trump erschießen, aber nicht, weil ähm,
Weil ähm,
Personen des besonderen öffentlichen Interesse und Politiker da einen besonderen Schutz haben, ja? Bilder von Tieren, die gequält werden, sind erlaubt,
kommt aber ein Satz hinzu, wie ich liebe, es zu sehen, wie Tiere leiden, dann wird das gelöscht.
Ähm Nacktfotos sind generell verboten, außer Nacktfotos von Holocaustopfern.
Denn dafür gibt es die Kategorie Holocaust Newity.
Und ja und die sind aber ja du erinnerst dich an diesen Skand. Ja, das klingt jetzt irgendwie, das ist makaber.
Sommercover.
Aber sie wollen die Auseinandersetzung mit wichtigen Bildern der Geschichte möglich machen. Wir erinnern uns ja an das äh an dieses nackte Kind, äh was da bei einem Naphalmangriff äh vor einem Naphalmangriff flüchtet,
und das.
Als eines der wichtigsten Pressefotos des Vietnamkriegs gilt, weil es eben zeigte, was die, was die USA da mit ihren Nahpalmenangriffen anrichteten und ähm,
Das wurde ja mal gelöscht, weil Newity und dann wurde es ja auch irgendwann wieder entlöscht. Ja, weil äh
politischer politischer Relevanz und unter der gleichen Maßgabe sagen sie eben auch so, ja, Holocaust-Munity ist okay,
Normale Judith nicht.
Ja, also genau, Staatsoberhäupter haben einen besonderen Schutz äh mit diesem äh jemand sollte Trump erschießen, geht halt ansonsten.
Wenn du sagst, wenn ich jetzt zu dir sagen würde, ich hoffe, dass dich jemand umbringt, das ist legitim, weil das also hoffen darf ich.
Ich darf aber nicht sagen, äh äh ich hasse Ausländer und werde sie alle erschießen. Das geht wieder um mich.
Und äh weil dann haben sie sogar noch so eine schöne ähm eine schöne ähm Matrix zur Bewertung von ähm von von Morddrohungen oder von generell Drohungen. Wenn ihr zum Beispiel sagst, äh,
Orte, ne, also ich weiß, wie du wohnst oder äh Art der Gewalt, Feuer, ja oder Zeitpunkt, ne? Also morgen bei dir vor der Tür.
Bring ich dich um, dann wird der Widimordrung für als glaubwürdiger beurteilt. Nun,
Das wird jetzt natürlich viel ähm viel anders zur Debatte geben. Es gibt auch Leute, die sich seit Jahren mit diesen
Regeln der sozialen Netzwerke auseinandersetzen, also Julian Jörg von der IFF ist da ein Beispiel die dann immer so Vorträge gehält über diese Nippeldebatten, ne? Da sind
männlicher Nippel, weiblicher Nippel und was nicht alles. Ähm.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da also da werden werden jetzt natürlich auch Widersprüche drin gefunden werden, aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht verkehrt, dass so etwas mal öffentlich zur Debatte,
kommt, weil das sind dann im Prinzip die effektiven Regeln
Der Meinungsfreiheit, wenn sie bei Facebook zum Einsatz kommen und die Menschen das für eine geeignete Plattform des Austausches halten.
Was ihr offensichtlich tun. Facebook ist nicht der einzige äh Container. Da gibt's natürlich auch noch ein paar andere in China, Russland et cetera wo Facebook jetzt nicht ganz so weit vorne ist, aber zumindest in der westlichen Welt und der,
uns hier so primär auch in Deutschland berührt. Da ist das halt so. Facebook ist für die Leute einfach der Ort, wo man äh die Dinge tut und dass andere Netz drumherum, na ja, das sind halt so ein paar Webheiten, passt Dienste
und irgendwas anderes war da auch noch.
Das ist natürlich nicht unsere technisch geprägte, historisch geprägte äh Sicht auf diese äh Sache und sicherlich wünscht man sich auch mal eine ähm wirtschaftliche Dynamik innerhalb des Netzes, die auch
Facebook nochmal in die Schranken weisen könnte. Ich glaube nur, dass es noch relativ weit weg. Zumal ihr,
äh einfach das Kapital und die Position haben. Sich potentielle äh Gegner schnell mal wegzukaufen. Siehe Instagram, et cetera,
WhatsApp. Alles wird dann schnell eingemeindet, wenn es auch nur ansatzweise bedrohlich sein kann.
Damit haben wir sozusagen eine voll privatisierte Zensur, dass das eigentlich noch schlimmer als ähm.
Als es staatlich organisierte äh Zensur, weil die ist zumindest na ja nicht transparent sagen, aber,
aber da da gibt es definierte Angriffspunkte, ja? Da gibt es da gibt es Verantwortlichkeiten, die auch äh
bei äh bei Fehlverhalten entsprechende Sanktionen nach sich ziehen können durch verlorene Wahlen oder andere Dinge
und das ist natürlich innerhalb des selbstgesetzten Riegelwerks eines solchen Unternehmens einfach nicht in dem selben Anmaß äh äh Ausmaß denkbar. Da geht's eigentlich nur um öffentliches Image, das ist schnell äh geschäpt,
zumal wenn irgendwie die ganze Debatte da drüber dann auch noch in ihrem eigenen Netzwerk stattfindet,
Also viel Spaß. Das wird noch äh lustig. Falls ihr euch schon immer mal gefragt habt, warum ich mich auf Facebook nicht groß rumtreibe, unter anderem deshalb.
Ich habe gerade was auf unserer äh Logbuchnetzpolitik Facebook-Seite veröffentlicht.
Haarverretter.
Ähm,
weil wir unbedingt unser Video in dieses Facebook reinbringen wollten und nicht den guten Namen des CC in den Schmutz ziehen, äh muss habe ich das gemacht, immer noch gut, jetzt mit dir. Wir haben nämlich ein Video gemacht. Ich bin jetzt Video äh Macher,
Ich hab ähm mit Starbuck habe ich ein Video gemacht. Hm denn es gibt ja die.
Also Starbuck ist derjenige aus dem CC, der inzwischen weltweit für seine Biometriehacks bekannt ist. Und immer wenn es irgendwie ein biometrisches,
ein Biometriesensor gibt, der besondere Sicherheit verspricht, dann sitzt Tabaken nachmittag im Keller im CCB und äh und macht macht das eben mal fertig.
Und baut also eine Attrappe, ne? Wir erinnern uns an den äh Finger äh Fingerabdrucksensor im,
im iPhone fünf S, der erste, der damals rauskam, wo er dann.
Quasi der quasi ein Foto von dem Fingerabdruck auf dem Display so weit verändert hat, dass das dann irgendwann in der Platine geätzt hat und dann mit der Platine eine Schablone hatte, um mit,
Holzleim einen Fingerabdruckaufsatz zu machen, dann mit ein klein bisschen Graffitsspray die Leitfähigkeit herzustellen, um dann diesen diese Attrappe auf seinen Finger zu legen,
das Telefon zu entsperren. Ähm, diesmal wurde das Samsung Galaxy S acht, musste dran glauben, denn die haben gesagt, ist doch voll die geile Idee, wenn wir einen Iris-Scanner in dieses Telefon einbauen. Ähm,
Also das das Telefon schießt mit so einem kleinen Infrarotlicht dann in deine Augen und ähm,
guckt sich dann an wie deine Iriden aussehen, ist nämlich die Merzahl von Iris, das haben wir alle, mussten wir alle im Duden nachschlagen.
Und dein individuelles Iris Muster ähm soll dann eben dabei helfen dieses,
Telefon äh oder dich gegenüber dem Telefon, als du auszuweisen und entsperrt
dann das Gerät und du kannst es auch nutzen für Samsung Pay und solche Scherze, ja? Jetzt wird den ein oder anderen aufgefallen sein, ähm dass man ja diese Iriden die ganze Zeit,
an seinem Kopf hat und äh ne also ich mein.
Diese Zeige, diese diese äh Fingerabdrücke, ne? Der Damm kannst du wenigstens hast du wenigstens zehn von, ne? Und der Sensor, der iPhone Sensor sagt ja nach dem Sohn zu finden, versuch nein, machen wir nicht mehr,
Von diesen Iriden hast du nur zwei und ähm insofern war dann das Angriffsszenario, was am Ende zum Erfolg geführt hat mit einer Kamera, die eine Nachtbildfunktion hat, Nachtbildfunktion heißt, man deaktiviert den Infrarot
Filter der Kamera, also diese äh Kamerasensoren sind eigentlich Pedifold, Infrarot empfindlich,
und dann liegt er halt ein kleiner Filter vor, der das Infrarotlicht herausfiltert.
Bei dieser Kamera, die wir da benutzt haben, irgendwie so eine alte Sony, kannst du die in den Nightshot Modus machen und dann ist die dann empfängt die eben auch Infrarot, entsprechend kannst du dann ein ganz gutes Bild von Iriden machen. Besser noch wird das, wenn du dann so ein Infrarot,
Scheinwerfer hast, ne, die ähm die man eigentlich hat für.
Für so über für Nachtsichtkameras, ne, dass du dann irgendwie der der Raum soll dunkel bleiben, du willst aber trotzdem was sehen, dann hast du halt diese hast du einfach einen Ray aus
Infrarotletz und äh ballasse halt damit, dann hast du halt so einen Nachtsichtscheinwerfer. Mit so einem kannst du natürlich noch besser machen, weil anders arbeitet das Telefon auch nicht, ne?
Also Borsten, Borsten halbwegs vernünftiges Infrarotbild der der Iris, des äh der Zielperson
und dann druckst du das aus und wenn du das dann dagegen hältst, dann passiert erstmal nichts
Ähm denn diese Biometriesensoren müssen müssen immer noch etwas machen, was sich Lebenderkennung heißt. Also sie, du machst den Biometriesensor ja im Prinzip dadurch sicher, dass er die Attrappe erkennt,
Aus diesem Grunde auch war es notwendig bei dem Fingerprintsensor des Graffit-Spray drüber zu machen, weil die Lebenderkennung über die Hautleitfähigkeit geht, ne? Das sagt also, ich will eine bestimmte Leitfähigkeit in dieser Oberfläche haben,
weil das zeigt mir, dass ich es mit mit Haut und nicht mit Wachs zu tun habe. Also musst du auch die Leitfähigkeit,
nachmachen. Und in diesem Falle ähm ging die Lebenderkennung offenbar über die ähm,
die Pupillenreflexion ähm häufig bei schlechteren Iriscannern geht das darüber, dass sie halt gucken, da muss irgendwo noch ein weißer Punkt sein,
natürlich schnell nachgemacht. Ähm, aber weil das Ding hier mit einer Kamera ist, wird er quasi auch sehen, wie sie sich bewegen. Letztendlich umgehen lässt sich das ganze Ding mit einer Kontaktlinse,
Du druckst also dieses Auge in in Originalgröße aus, ja? Äh original skaliert und legst dann genau über diese Pupille eine.
Eine Kontaktlinse, damit du dieses Glänzen hast, ne, den den Lichtendverhältnissen entsprechen und das Auge nach einem echten Auge aussieht. Und siehe da, ähm so lässt sich dann das Samsung,
S acht entsperren.
Surprise, Surprise.
Und wir werden wir werden ja nie müde zu betonen. Deswegen mach des also Biometrie ist grundsätzlich dumm
Ja, also grundsätzlich, also als einziger, als einziges Authentifizierungsmerkmal, ja? Das als Nutzername zu nehmen, in Kombination mit einem Passwort, wer uns was, was ich mir total wünschen würde bei diesem verfluchten iPhone,
dass du den Fingerabdruck drauf hälst und das sagt, alles klar? Das war jetzt die erste Hälfte deines Pins. Jetzt musst du nur noch,
vier Zeichen eingeben statt acht. Ne, das wäre, das fände ich, das wäre das Feature, weil's, was ich eigentlich gerne hätte.
Also Biometrie als als einer von mehreren Faktoren.
Ja oder oder eben mit mit eingeschränkter äh Sicherheit, ne, Timeouts et cetera,
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie am laufenden Meter dein Telefon in der Hand hältst und äh sich das immer wieder äh lockt, meine Vorteil
beim iPhone zum Beispiel ist ja auch, dass es einfach dazu führt, dass die Telefone überhaupt gelockt werden,
weil die Leute vorher einfach diese Pins nicht vergeben haben, wer da entsprechend äh sensitiv ist, äh hat das sicherlich schon immer anders gehandhabt, aber das Hauptproblem war, dass die Leute einfach
darauf verzichtet haben, aus Convenience Gründen und äh oder dass dann eben in dem Moment, wo es auf sie
erzwungen, also wo es erzwungen worden wäre, dass sie auf jeden Fall eine PIN haben müssen, dass dann sozusagen als ja
will ich nicht haben äh Effekt äh von den Telefonen eben auch äh abschreckt. So und deswegen ist diese Kombination meiner Meinung nach
jetzt nicht die allerschlechteste, aber du hast natürlich recht.
Biometrie, man muss sich immer klar machen äh versucht einen Schlüssel zu verstecken, den man eigentlich mehr oder weniger offen herumträgt und von dem man eben auch nicht so viele hat.
Und man will eben.
Nicht neu ausdenken kann.
Man will eben mit seinen Schlüsseln ähm man will Schlösser wechseln können und das ist eben bei Biometrie äh fundamental nicht mehr möglich
und es ist spätestens seit äh in der in der CC Datenschleuder vor weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren der Fingerabdruck von Wolfgang Schäuble veröffentlicht wurde. Ne, das sind ja dann immer die Aktionen, die
diese Grenzen hier auch mal klar machen sollen, ne.
Nun ja, aber es war, es war ein Spaß und es hat hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und ähm ich äh hatte freue mich über über das Video und äh,
wenn freue mich, wenn ihr das anklickt.
Ja, ist ganz lustig geworden. Wo wir schon bei Videos sind, gibt da einen neuen Film. Ich habe davon auch schon gehört, hast du ihn schon gesehen? Oder reden wir nur.
Wir wollen denen empfehlen, der lief auf dem ähm der lief auf dem dreiunddreißig C drei schon.
Ja, da haben wir einen äh sehr spontan war das. Also es war so, wie der der erste Vortrag,
beim dreiunddreißig zu drei in Saal eins war ja The Global Assacination Grit von Jean West Malend. Ein auch einem Aussteiger aus dem US-Drohnenprogramm.
Und der hatte die Regisseurin Sonja Kennebeck äh dabei, habe ich den Namen jetzt richtig aus,
ja ne und die hat dann bei dieser Gelegenheit auch äh auf ihren Film aufmerksam gemacht National Bird, der sich kritisch mit dem,
Thema des US-Drohnenkrieges auseinandersetzt, ja? Also mit Leuten, die darin gearbeitet haben, spricht und diese neuen,
Die Bedingungen dieser Art der Kriegsführung,
insbesondere auch die psychologischen Bedingungen unter denen das stattfindet, sowohl für die in den USA sitzenden Drown-Operators, die irgendwie.
Paar Stunden Videospiel spielen so ungefähr und äh am anderen Ende der Welt äh alles in Schutt und Asche legen. Äh wie auch über diese Befehlshierarchie, wie eben da die die Tötungsentscheidungen,
auf verschiedene Ebenen gelegt wird, ja? Also,
diese Verantwortungsverlegung, dass derjenige, der am Ende die Verantwortung trägt, am weitesten weg von der Tötung ist, ne.
Um so diese Entscheidung einfacher treffen zu können.
Und äh da davon handelt eben dieser Film. Hat äh sehr sehr gute Bewertungen, aber wie das eben so ist,
es ist eine Indipendentokumentation und solche finden grundsätzlich unter massiven,
oder großen finanziellen Schwierigkeiten,
statt. So und jetzt hatte dieser äh Film und jetzt kündigen wir jetzt auch ein bisschen spät leider an. Ähm in diesen in den letzten Tagen eine Kinotour, ja? Ähm.
Uns die begannen irgendwie am dreizehnten fünften und geht jetzt noch bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten fünften. Wir waren in,
in Berlin, Kaiserslautern, Stuttgart, Freiburg, München, Seefeld, Heidelberg und jetzt sind sie am fünfundzwanzigsten fünften nochmal in Lich im Traumstern
Und die sind dann eben in also in Anwesenheit der Regisseurin, das ist auch wirklich eine sehr ähm fitte,
Patente Frau, die auskunftsfähig ist und in der man auch gerne zuhört.
Also lichtlich ist bei Frankfurt.
Bei Frankfurt, sondern bietet sich doch mal an, ähm dass da vielleicht noch äh mit dem GPN-Besuch in Karlsruhe zu verbinden oder.
Also noch näher bei Gießen, um genau zu sein, also Gießen, Wetzlar, die Ecke ist das.
So oder so brauchen wir äh solche.
Solche Filme und sollten das unterstützen, um ähm auch in Zukunft zu zeigen, dass es für solche Filme eben,
auch ein Markt gibt, damit eben solche Filme auch in Zukunft noch von irgendjemanden finanziert werden können. Ähm, und deswegen sei hier nochmal,
dafür geworben diesen Film irgendwie kommerziell,
zu sich zu nehmen und zu gucken, in welchen Kinos der noch läuft. Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass in allen diesen Kinos wahrscheinlich mindestens noch eine Woche läuft. Du machst ja nicht eine Einmalaufführung.
Das weiß ich aber leider nicht so genau. Wichtig ist, dass es dann, dass ihr den auch dann eben bald schaut, weil ähm ne für die Entscheidung, ob der Film nochmal eine Woche länger läuft,
ist, sind entscheidend die Anspielzahlen in der ersten Woche. Also,
guckt wo bei euch irgendwie National Bird läuft, schaut euch den an, wenn man allein schon den Trailer schaut, sieht man, dass das ein Film ist, der echt unter die Haut geht, mit krassen Bildern arbeitet, mit krassen Aussagen,
kann man nur ähm empfehlen.
Ja und dann ähm gibt's ja auch noch Linus im Fernsehen, immer wieder anzukündigen äh anzugucken. Jetzt bist du mir so mit Widner Houston auf einen.
Hast du nicht den erste nicht diesen Tweet von Chaos Updates gesehen? Also,
Also wenn man äh wenn man auf Twitter einen Link twittert, ja, äh dann wird der bei bestimmten Seiten, die das mit einem kleinen HTML Snippet äh Twitter erlauben.
Privio.
Preview gemacht, ja? Und das Sendungsbild ähm,
dieser Sendung, bei der ich zu Gast war, war eben eins von Witney Houston. So und äh der der Twitter-Account Chaos Updates twitterte dann irgendwie heute Abend bei ZDF Aspekte Linus Neumann und dadrunter war dann eben ein großes Bild von,
was äh ich sehr, was ich amüsant fand,
Ja ich war da nochmal kurz kurz zu Gast in der Sendung ZDF Aspekte vom neunzehnten Mai zu diesem ganzen Geheimdienste und Cybertheater,
Und ähm war angenehm überrascht, also diese dieses die Sendung war, also sie haben ja mehrere Themen, die anderen Themen waren auch irgendwie interessant und äh in guten Beiträgen aufgearbeitet. Das Team war sehr nett und,
Kann man sich echt mal anschauen? War fand ich echt überraschend.
Ja, Aspekte hat auch hat auch so eine ganz angenehme Interviewkultur. Also die unterhalten sich da irgendwie ziemlich normal mit einem.
Die haben sich längere so sechs Minuten oder sowas mit mir unterhalten und waren,
freundlich aufgeschlossen, wissbegierig, das ist das ist ein gutes Team, gute Moderatoren, gutes Moderatorenteam, Kati und Jo.
Ähm trotzdem äh durchaus ernste Themen ähm,
das ich kannte die Sendung vorher nicht. Ähm nee kannte ich nicht. Ich habe ja keinen Fernseher. Und ähm das war äh.
Immer eine Ausnahme gewesen im deutschen Fernsehen. Ist halt eine Kultursendung, ne, die sich aber eben auch sehr breit äh dem dem diesen Basisthema stellt und immer wieder interessante Sachen aufgreift.
War ich von von angetan. Ja, das war's.
Schlimm ist es doch gar nicht. Alter, die fliegen zu den Drohnen übern Kopf, die.
Lange Sendung geworden. Na ja gut, sie werden äh anderthalb Stunden, wir haben uns beeilt. Das Desaster. Ja, wir haben uns beeilt.
Geht gar nicht, also für für das Ausmaß des Desasters ist noch nicht mal eineinhalb Stunden, wenn wir vorher irgendwie noch ein bisschen rumgekaspert.
Stimmt.
Ja, dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch äh dem Benjamin und dem Alexander zu danken. Auf die GPN am Wochenende hinzuweisen, wo man natürlich hingehen kann.
In Karlsruhe die Veranstaltung des Entropia.
Haben wir ja schon gemacht. Haben wir schon gemacht. Machen wir jetzt nicht nochmal aus.
Haben wir schon gemacht. Habe ich aber schon.
Hast du aber schon gemacht? Ja.
Und sonst noch irgendwas, ja.
Ne. Diese Woche wieder.
Habe ich schon gedacht, nee, nee, Benjamin und Alexander. Vielen herzlichen Dank, habe ich gedankt. Och, kein Sieht man echt, dass ich jetzt durch bin, ne? Was ist nochmal mit dem EAD Gese.
Ja, hast du schon getan? Du bist total durch. Jetzt nochmal Benjamin Alexander danken.
Habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Tschüss.
Ciao ciao.